our ongoing series a more perfect union
aims to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning we introduced
you to a couple from Milwaukee whose
lifetime interest in investment and
investment in art is benefiting the
local community Niki batiste shows us
how they're painting a hopeful pickar
picture thank you good morning good
morning Tony and Pat buso lackeys art
collection featured inside their
retirement community is a portrait of
their nearly six decades Ernie together
a journey that now finds them giving
back to the city they've called home
nearly all their life this is called a
Madonna with tears of diamonds for his
85th birthday Tony boo so lucky wanted
to paint a picture that may be his most
valuable work of art yet how many of
these pieces out here this is all mine
these are all your all my stuff down Wow
his wish this year is a gesture of
kindness helping strangers I read this
article about the hospital being
converted into low-income housing and I
said I'd like to do something for my
birthday for other people it was Saint
Anthony's Hospital
oh yeah Saint Anthony's house and I had
been born there I named after yeah they
said we need a thousand dollars for each
of the 60 apartments to furnish and then
the light went on and I said how would
it be if we sell some of our art and
give you the proceeds they said it was a
young man that bought the one piece of
gory enchant throughout their 58 years
of marriage patent Tony boo so lucky
have invested a lifetime of research and
money into art that's based on Matisse
some is Tony's work and other pieces
acquired from their travels around the
globe I'm thrilled at the thought that
all this art could be used to make other
people's lives better we were crossing a
little bridge Tony a retired teacher and
military veteran pledged to sell 85
different works only a fraction of their
collection one for each year of his life
the proceeds will be donated to the st.
Anthony apartment project ceilings which
is still under construction the program
will provide 60 housing units and
supportive services for Milwaukee's most
needy we rely on the generosity of
people Pat and Tony are doing a huge
thing hi there
brother Rob Romer ministry director at
Capetian services is helping oversee the
program it just makes my heart melt I
just as so is so touching to hear the
stories of why people want to help and I
find the people Milwaukee very generous
I'm looking at things disappearing and
I'm thinking they're gonna have to go up
and take stuff off their wall Toni and
Pat's art sale was an overwhelming
success generating at least $20,000 and
for those less fortunate generating some
hope you're giving so much more than
just an apartment I think for these 60
people we're giving them some dignity I
never tell people have a nice day
I always tell people make it a good day
perfect
so what we're attempting to do with this
art project is we're trying to make it a
good day
initially Patton Toni Onley expected to
fetch a few thousand dollars worth of
donations but since their art sale they
say they're still feeling donations for
their artwork Toni says he's overwhelmed
by the generosity he's seen from the
Milwaukee community so they made a lot
of good days Nikki a lot of good days
and Toni says his mom taught him to
always give to the less fortunate so no
doubt she's very proud message delivered
I like I like the name Patton Toni boo
so lucky
very nice thank you so much thank you
thank you so much to you